en el primer vídeo sobre inmunología
hablamos de los mecanismos de defensa no
específicos mencionamos que si tenemos
un cierto tipo de patógeno digamos una
bacteria que nuestros fagocitos puedan
reconocer ya sea por las proteínas en la
bacteria o tal vez algún otro tipo de
marcador en el patógeno aunque no sepa
qué tipo de patógeno es esto es
suficiente para que el pago citó y
quiera al patógeno
así que dibujemos al fagocitó y de
alguna manera uno de sus receptores toca
una de las proteínas que está en la
superficie de la bacteria y dice caramba
aquí tenemos una cosa que no es bueno
tener alrededor así que me lo tragaré
entonces la membrana empezará a rodear
al patógeno y esta parte empezará a
entrar parecido a hundirse y el patógeno
quedará encerrado y entonces será
tragado
fagocitado por el favorcito vimos esto
en el primer vídeo en el que hablamos de
fagocitosis la membrana lo rodeará por
completo ya que esta parte se hundirá
y se formará una burbuja alrededor del
patógeno entonces tendremos al patógeno
dentro del fagocitó rodeado de una
membrana cuyo nombre es fago soma además
aprendimos que hay distintos tipos de
fagocitos pueden ser macrófagos pueden
ser neutrófilos pueden ser células
dendríticas y todo esto lo vimos en ese
vídeo y aquí no acaban los macrófagos no
sólo digieren esta cosa esto por sí
mismo es demasiado útil pero si tenemos
esta bacteria fuera del camino o si
fuera un virus
tenemos un virus fuera del camino
entonces estos macrófagos hacen incluso
más que eso toman el patógeno y después
destruyen su membrana o podemos decir
que lo descomponen
otra forma de pensar que lo procesa
entonces descompone al patógeno en otro
vídeo de fagocitosis vimos que tenemos
un enlace de lisosomas en él y vierten
todo tipo de partículas que van a
descomponer y romper esta bacteria en
este caso en sus moléculas
constituyentes vamos a dibujarlo llegan
vierten su contenido y descomponen todo
y después una parte de las obras en
particular cadenas de los polipéptidos
recuerdan las proteínas son largas
cadenas de aminoácidos mientras que los
polipéptidos son cadenas cortas entonces
estas cadenas cortas se van a enlazar
con las proteínas especiales y este es
justo el tema principal de este vídeo
así que vamos a decir que se enlazan con
esta proteína especial y con esta otra y
estas proteínas son transportadas o
vamos a decir que se llevan a la
membrana oa la superficie exterior de la
célula
se presentan junto con una pieza del
patógeno entonces el producto final
después de favor citar este patógeno es
un favorcito que se va a ver algo así
vamos a tener estas proteínas
presentadoras de antígeno podemos
llamarlas así que se enlazaron con
partes del patógeno original así que
vamos a ponerlo tenemos un poco del
patógeno original justo por aquí y estas
proteínas tienen un nombre elegante como
mencionamos en el vídeo pasado se llaman
complejos mayores de histocompatibilidad
o cnh para abreviar y cuando hablamos de
fagocitos por ejemplo los macrófagos o
células dentríticas los complejos
mayores de histocompatibilidad que se
presentan después de que han digerido
esta molécula son ce m h clase 2
y parece que vamos a entrar en detalles
minuciosos sobre estas proteínas pero
como veremos este complejo es clave para
activar otras partes del sistema
inmunológico en especial las partes
mediadas por las células del sistema
inmunológico bueno en este caso con un
macrófago o una dentríticas ingieren
algo lo mastican por completo y después
partes de lo que masticaron las adjuntan
a estas proteínas cmt2 las cuales van a
la superficie de la célula una cosa
similar pasa con las células
vamos a dibujar las de color azul
sabemos que la p viene de bursa que el
latín significa bolsa vamos a decir que
tenemos una célula pem y que podemos
decir que tiene su anticuerpo unido a la
membrana recuerda esto es muy específico
de las células p todos los anticuerpos
enlazados en la membrana los 10.000 o
algo así
esta célula ve expresan la misma parte
variable aquí dibujamos una célula en
particular y recuerda esto no es
específico cuando hablamos de
fagocitosis los fagocitos dicen oye tú
eres una bacteria o un virus
realmente no sé qué tipo eres yo
solamente te comeré te ves sospechoso no
sé quién eres o si te he visto antes
pero te voy a comer cuando hablamos de
las células p
hablamos de un sistema adaptable o del
sistema inmunológico específico entonces
las terminaciones variables de estos
anticuerpos unidos a las membranas son
específicos a ciertas partes de ciertos
patógenos a ciertos epítopos recuerda un
epítopos es una parte del patógeno que
estas cadenas específicas pueden
reconocer para adherirse así que vamos a
imaginar que estamos trabajando con un
virus en esta ocasión y vamos a decir
que el virus simplemente se puede
adherir
a esta célula ve recuerda puede haber
otra de hecho
en definitiva hay montones de otras
células
alrededor pero sus partes variables son
diferentes por eso las pondremos de un
color distinto esto me parece bastante
sorprendente porque las células p vienen
de la misma línea genética sus genes han
sido mezclados en su desarrollo y por lo
tanto pueden producir miles de millones
de combinaciones de estas proteínas o de
estas terminaciones variables de sus
anticuerpos bien ahora pensamos que
tenemos un virus o digamos una bacteria
y cuando hicimos el otro ejemplo de las
células p mencionamos que estábamos
tratando con un virus pero esta vez
vamos a pensar en una bacteria y una
parte de su superficie simplemente se
enlaza a estas células porque tiene la
combinación exacta así que una parte de
esta superficie se une a esta célula ve
justo aquí
esta parte que se une a la superficie
recordemos tiene el nombre de [ __ ] pong
y esa es la parte del patógeno que se
une al secuenciador variable no se unirá
a esta célula be ni a esta otra ya que
ellas tienen distintos secuenciadores y
cuando se une a esta célula be empieza
el proceso de activación
algunas veces esto por sí solo puede
activar a la célula ve pero normalmente
necesita ayuda de las células t
colaboradoras pero hablaremos de ello en
un momento y una vez que se activa o que
empieza el proceso de activación se
ingiere este patógeno y no hablamos de
esto en el vídeo pasado porque no
entramos en muchos detalles
entonces la célula ingiere todo esto y
después de activarse proliferan y
normalmente necesita ayuda de las
células t justo aquí
y parte de ellas se convierten en
células plasmáticas mientras que la otra
parte se convierte en células de memoria
recuerda las células plasmáticas dicen
vaya ahora que he sido activada voy a
producir un montón de estos anticuerpos
así que las células plasmáticas producen
un montón de estos anticuerpos y
empiezan a lanzarlos hacia afuera para
que puedan unirse a más y más patógenos
para estropearlo en varias formas ya sea
etiquetando los por ejemplo los verdes
son los patógenos y así otros macrófagos
o fagocitos los coman o etiquetando dos
de ellos para agruparlos y que no puedan
operar de manera adecuada por ahora no
vamos a entrar en detalles de esto pero
esto es lo que pasa cuando se activa lo
que es interesante es que la célula ve
también hace lo mismo que los fagocitos
las células ven también
al patógeno en la célula tal vez
inicialmente esté unido al anticuerpo lo
disuelven lo descomponen y toman piezas
del patógeno que adjuntan a las
proteínas de smh para después
presentarlas en la superficie
entonces las células también presentan
este antígeno así que también es cm2
complejo mayor de histocompatibilidad de
hecho esto significa tejido así que esto
está relacionado con los tejidos en
nuestro cuerpo y hablaremos de eso y de
cómo está relacionado con los
trasplantes en un futuro entonces esto
también es cnh 2 en ambos casos ya sea
que hablemos de las células que
reconocen un patógeno de forma muy
específica pueden ser un virus o una
proteína o una bacteria en específico o
el caso de los fagocitos que dicen tú te
ves sospechoso así que voy a comerte sin
importar qué tipo de bacteria o virus o
proteínas seas en ambos casos se ingiere
al patógeno se disuelve se toman piezas
de él y las presentan en la superficie
en un complejo mayor de
histocompatibilidad
así que a las células que hacen esto se
les conoce como células presentadoras de
antígeno profesionales profesionales
porque esto es lo que hacen para vivir a
pesar de que hacen otras cosas como
veremos después los fagocitos comen
cosas y las células ve generar
anticuerpos o memorias de modo que
puedan ser activadas para generar
anticuerpos a estas se les conoce como
células presentadoras de antígeno
profesionales y el antígeno en cuestión
es esta pequeña pieza de la cosa que se
intenta rastrear esta pequeña pieza con
la parte del patógeno
este es el antígeno así que presentan el
antígeno de nuevo son profesionales
porque toman a los patógenos del fluido
de nuestro sistema los ingieren los
descomponen y los presentan
ahora existen también células no
profesionales presentadoras de antígeno
y de hecho la mayoría de las células son
así pero de eso hablaremos en el
siguiente vídeo ya que todos los vídeos
están quedando muy largos así que
seguramente estarás pensando ok
en ambos casos estas células ingieren
descomponen y presentan pero para qué
sirve esto podemos ver que estos cnh
todos son reconocidos por las células de
colaboradoras y todo esto es parte del
rompecabezas de cómo funciona nuestro
sistema inmunológico así que en el
siguiente vídeo hablaremos de las
células presentadoras cnh 1 que son casi
todas las demás células del cuerpo